you worked at IBM for over 40 years
starting as a systems engineer and you
ran the company as chairman president
CEO from 2011 to 2020 IBM is one of the
largest tech companies in the world with
maybe you can correct me on this with
with about 280 000 employees what are
the biggest challenges running the
company of that size let's start with us
at a big overview question
biggest challenges I think are not in
running them isn't changing them
and that idea to know what you should
change and what you should not change
actually people don't always ask that
question what should endure even if it
has to be modernized but what should
endure and then I found the hardest part
was changing how work got done it's such
a big company what was the parts that
you thought should endure the core of
the company that was beautiful and
powerful and could persist through time
that it should persist through time I'd
be interested do you have a perception
of what you think it would be
do I have a perception well I'm a
romantic for a history of long-running
companies so there's kind of a a
tradition as a AI person to me IBM has
some epic sort of research
accomplishments yes where you show off
you know uh deep blue and Watson just
impressive big moonshot challenges and
accomplishing those but that's I think
that's probably a small part of what IBM
is that's mostly like the the the sexy
public facing part yeah that no it is
well certainly the research part itself
right is over three thousand so it's not
that small that's a pretty big research
yes but the part that should endure ends
up being
you know company that does things that
are essential to the world meaning
um
the who you know think back you said
you're a romantic it was the 30s the
social security system it was putting
the man on the moon it was you know to
this day Banks don't run you know
railroads don't run uh
that is at its core it's doing Mission
critical work and so that part I think
is at its core it's a business to
business company
and at its course about doing things
that are really important to the world
be coming running and being better
running the infrastructure of the world
so doing it at scale doing it reliably
yes secure in this world that's like
everything and in fact when I started I
almost felt people were looking for what
that was and together we sort of in a
word was to be essential and the reason
I loved that word was I can't call
myself essential you have to determine I
am right so it was to be essential even
though some of what we did is exactly
what you said it's below the surface so
many people because people say to me
what does IBM do now right and over the
years it's changed so much and today
it's really a software and consulting
company consulting's a third of it and
the software is all hybrid cloud and AI
that would not have been true as you
well know back even two decades ago
right so
um it changes but I think at its core
it's that be essential you said moonshot
can all be moonshots because moonshots
don't always work but Mission critical
work so so
given the size though
when you started running it did you feel
the sort of thing that people usually
associate with size which is bureaucracy
and maybe the aspect of size that hinder
progress or hinder pivoting did you feel
that you would
um for lots of reasons I think when
you're a big company
sometimes people think of processes the
client themselves you know I always say
to people your process is not your
customer there is a real customer here
that you exist for and that's really
easy to fall into because they're you
know people are a master or to this
process and that's not right and when
you're big the other thing in boy
there's a premium on it is speed right
that in our industry you got to be fast
and go back like when I took over and it
was 2012.
you know we had a lot of catching up to
do and a lot of things to do and it was
moving so fast and as you well know all
those Trends were happening at once
which made them go even faster and so
pretty unprecedented actually for that
many Trends to be at one time and I used
to say to people go faster go faster go
faster and honestly
I've tired them out I mean it kind of
dawned on me that when you're that big
yeah that's a really valuable lesson and
it taught me like the house perhaps more
important than the what because
if I didn't do something to change how
work was done like change those
processes or you know give them new
tools help them with skills
they couldn't they're just like do the
same thing faster if someone tells you
you know you've got hiking boots and
they're like no go run a marathon you're
like I can't do it in those boots but so
you've got to do something and at first
I think the ways for big companies I
would call them like blunt clubs you do
what everyone does you reduce layers
because if you reduce layers decisions
go faster there's just it's math if
there's less decision points things go
faster
um you do the blunt Club thing and then
after that though it did lead me down a
you know a long journey of they sound
like buzzwords but if you really do them
at scale they're hard around things like
agile and um because you've really got
to change the way work gets done and we
ended up training God hundreds of
thousands of people on that stuff
correctly on how to do it correctly
that's right versus because everybody
talks about it but the idea that you
would really have small
multi-disciplinary teams work from the
outside in set those sort of interim
steps you know take the feedback pivot
and then do it on not just products do
it on lots of things was it's a hard to
do at scale um people always say oh I
got this agile group over here of 40
people but not when you're a couple
hundred thousand people you got to get a
lot of people to work that way the blunt
Club thing you're talking about so
flatten the organization as much as
possible yeah yeah I probably reduce the
layers of management by half and so it
that does that has lots of benefits
right time to a decision
um more autonomy to people because and
then the idea of like faster Clarity of
of where you're going because you're not
just filtered through so many different
layers and I think it's the kind of
thing a lot of companies if you're big
have to just keep going through it's
kind of like Grass Grows you know it
just comes back and you gotta go back
down and uh and work on it so it's a
natural thing
um but I hear so many people talk about
it like this idea of like okay who makes
a decision you've often heard nobody can
say yes and everybody can say no and
that's actually what you're trying to
get out of a system like that